strategy is super important in eSports
the ability to out think ones opponent
is what separates good teams from great
ones but sometimes you just need that
quick kill that quick map sometimes just
kind of bring out the cheese now look it
can be frustrating in ranks but in
professional play it can be devastating
so sit back grab yourself a sleeve of
crackers and some artisanal meats
because these are the top ten cheese
strats in eSports believe it or not
before it was picked by everyone and
their mother teleport was a cheesy
summoner spell used for annoying strats
which is why it comes in at number 10 in
our list throughout 2012 clg's marque
cheese at tournaments was this super
annoying combination of triple TP and
promote 35 minutes into the match
CLG finally found their chance and
unleashed one of the cheesiest backdoors
we've ever seen now we see boy boy toy
pudding they've grown into the face
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's worse than the opponent cannon
rushing your main how about your
opponent cannon rushing all of your
expansion at the same time poor sue fell
victim to this super cheesy strat from
classic in the group stage of GSL season
2 and it comes in at number 9 on our
list oh look at this he's even making
roaches right now this is he's like
Swiss cheese or Kota cheese this is like
straight-up
cheese that was made in a lab it's like
that plastic cheese you got under subway
sandwich it is made by scenario cheese
yep we are this is real guys sue tried
his hardest to overcome classic with an
army of roaches and a Hail Mary nightís
worm but the cheese proved too strong to
beat all right well let's see what he
gets done with this probably not a lot
since immortals are already popping out
he has cannons at the front like this is
this one's pretty much a dead in the
water I would say sue is not going to
win this game folks don't spoil it
fresher kosis no make it exciting for us
make it exciting for light of you now
okay we have the cheesiest flag I love
it I love it he's drink that cheese down
yes at number 8 we have an overwatch
play from season 2 of a GN sold apex
tournament Mehta Athena got the jump on
lunatic high thanks to a cheesy boost
from their DPS libero playing may libero
used his ice wall to boost his team over
a boundary allowing meta Athena to flank
and wipe an unsuspecting lunatic high
with some high-grade cheddar
oh okay this is gonna be a long link
actually very long payload is not over
there it's okay they're gonna try and
take the high ground up for that boost
on top of the high ground this what is
this I love inna coming down logic is no
idea they're coming from this angle
don't go back up though they had a hunch
that something was going on if they get
walled off during the Rhinehart charge
though grandpa'll time bluetick I'm
trying to hold Nana boo set both
Reinhard's libero firing away with those
right clicks and they find them
sometimes offensive met Athena get the
kills they'd be eaten that is actually
brilliant I mean just fantastic news so
been Athena had a couple of tricks going
for them there and one of them works
this is a player manages to reposition
the Los Angeles gladiators earn the
number seven spot with their cheesy
King's row strat from the o WL season
one playoff quarterfinals by rushing
behind the London Spitfire as soon as
the match began the gladiators corralled
their opponents into the sites of their
Widowmaker
the Spitfire didn't know sure for was
there because he hadn't picked her yet I
feel like more recently we're not asking
what silk thread can't do anymore or
kind of asking what he can so many
different heroes that he can sort of
bring out that's it was very effective
okay I like this for the Gladius this is
this is cheap better train circle around
the Spitfire what interrupt this a
little bit here where are you going
where are you oh this is so not chump
was telling in small so he's waiting
here we can sort of walk now what I'll
try to do is I think he's gonna either
he's gonna either switch to widow-makers
how cool this the merry-go-round because
that makes me laugh makes me happy it
shortens it drops down today the
shooting range for the best laid plans
fail but not this one big flame from the
gladiators in a let loose the widow at
just the right time look I know this is
runescape but hear me out
this guy walks was playing in
RuneScape's Deadman mode seasonal think
Battle Royale
but in runescape instead of playing as
intended
MOOCs created a masterful cheese sitting
in the fog eating lobsters to survive
yes you heard right
lobsters he is boss all his food and he
is constantly at using a files to
unknown items on the each day and even
though 15 whoops collected his food
avoided all combat and headed to an NPC
who can convert Bank noted items into
real usable ones and just keep on eating
hello it's now then the jail zone there
he is he's rotted away unfortunate for
him but yep boots the last man 58 you
got killed
we're gonna wait for the pewter caters
yeah assess that situation let's know
who the true winner is eg yeah the
question is right now Ian as is that
gonna be allowed our will lololololol
take a win despite winning the event
rooks was disqualified for his cheese
losing the $10,000 prize
fortunately runescape legend mod ash saw
this injustice and donated $10,000 -
woofs proving the cheese really does
payoff at number five we have a play
that would make the score esports his
greatest hits I'm talking about no tide
hunters famous roshan bait from
dreamhack 2012 while the play is
ingenious it's also super cheesy
admiralbulldog tricked eg into thinking
they were going for a level one Roshan
by dying to it his bait worked and eg
came to check Roshan springing no tide
hunters trap and well you know the rest
if you're looking to pull if you're
looking to do anything else you've got
to keep your eyes open for that one and
wow admiralbulldog giving a freebie and
here we go uh-huh game is on a is lane
there's a small blood patch were admiral
bullet and it is it's actually trapped
because they came to check for it
oh now what is this we may pull
something out of the bag and feat is
gonna go down as well Oh hunter water
stop what a strategy coming out from
eternal Envy the Prophet Bey he doesn't
lose any gold anything by suiciding to
Rocha it's a pure bait he spent all his
gold on standing on him and no China
just come right out get two kills right
up the back no one has ever done that no
one has ever done that in the history of
dota
at number four is league of legends is
classic fnatic death brush which has
since become the game's quintessential
cheese-making its competitive debut at
the season 1 world championship in 2011
the death brushes first professional
casualty was none other than everybody's
favorite group stage ad carry double
lift double if walking right into the
bush you will face like this and he
could be going down he is absolutely
going down the first hill I come out
before a minute of the game and fnatic
starts this one off letting epic as a
gaming know that they are ready to play
in this one and nope
they're still standing there who wants
to go in the basement the so-called
fanatic death brush has become a go-to
cheese for pros and plebs alike though
it may not always go as planned but in a
pinch the death brush can be the perfect
cheese to get your team back in the game
sitting atop them are they backing are
they waiting to go in so as you guys
have to have would be very aggressive
but the DAAD comes in from behind get
your angry comments ready because for
number three on this list we're talking
about the Olaf boost look even if it is
overplayed this cheese is legendary
prettiest and a game of oh do they have
a width roost going on currently you
know the story dreamhack winter 2014
fanatics facing ldlc in map 3 of the
quarterfinals down 12 to 3 with their
backs against the wall
Olaf jumps on top of Crim's and reveals
a truly unfair boost he sees them now
this straight headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed and
see they just lost around to it and they
they still have no sure that just
getting fired
there it is is rainy down death to
repose you know a place cheesy if it
gets banned right after you use it in
fact even though it one fanatic the
series the play was so controversial the
tournament organizers asked them to
replay the map and they eventually
forfeited taking this lists number two
spot is a play that's almost 16 years
old going back to the 2004 OSL
semi-finals one of brood wars most
legendary players boxer was pitted up
against his rival yellow so how did
boxer carve his path to the OSL finals
well through a cheesy bunker rush of
course but boxer didn't just cheese
yellow once
[Music]
or twice
the guy won all three maps with the same
cheese three games in a row and each
game ended faster than the last
you think yellow would have learned by
the second bunker rush topping our list
is competitive DotA's most infamous
cheese that's right I'm talking about
the fountain hook combo from the
International 2013 on the verge of
defeat against tongfu in the upper
bracket of ti3 na vi's dendi and puppey
hatched a brilliant plan and tongfu is
going to continue to push they're not
done mac still hasn't even been used
there's a hook how brought all the way
back to the base cleaned up by the
fountain
we actually just saw the chin Pudge
combo at the international that happened
Dendi hooked the enemy as Pudge and then
was instantly transported to the
fountain by puppy's chin pulling his
victim all the way there with him Navi
though in position they might try
something Cindy is gonna try it again
Kenny got in that time seeing the pace
move welcome home
suppose not that he needed to gives him
that little assistance fountain hooking
not only one Navi the game it ignited
the community in the process you guys
don't deserve it or something like that
and they're like whatever dude for all
of the laughs and anger it incited with
in dota fans before it was patched out
na vi's fountain hook is the greatest
cheese in the eSports history well guys
that's our list those are the oldest
stinkiest and most full-bodied cheese's
in all of these sports make sure to LIKE
the video subscribe to our Channel and
let us know in the comments become
cheesier into it see you next time three
cheese's top three cheese's I would say
3 smoked gouda - is Jarlsberg and number
one is that first round of the lower
bracket a TI that Bo one when you get
like the broom other mid and then and
and the me PO that's my favorite kind of
cheese I look forward to that cheese I
wait all year for that cheese for that
one night when they play those four
rounds
[Music]